yeah i mean ii Delic world is very white
and male in America yes and I've noticed
that from the beginning most of the you
know people you most of the researchers
are white male most of the scientist
which was my focus and you look at the
history and most of the big characters
in the history have been white men do I
perpetuate that by writing about them I
guess I do there are some really
important female characters in this book
though and some of them people of color
maria sabina for example the woman who
turned on Gordon Watson and really led
to brought psilocybin to the West
inadvertently and that was you know
that's not a happy story for her in the
end that that you know led to the
essentially the destruction of her
little village in Oaxaca as celebrities
descended and her house was burned down
by her by people in the village they
were so mad at her she regretted having
done it but anyway there's a there's a
very important woman of color in this
narrative of the guides I work with I
work with three guides two of them were
women
Mary one of them is really kind of the
hero of the book in many ways are there
women that I overlooked I'm sure there
are and you know some of that is no
doubt a result of my perspective but a
lot of it as a result of the history
that I was writing about you could write
an alternative history of psychedelics
and you could talk all about Albert
Hoffman's assistant and Gordon Watson's
wife and you know so there's is there a
feminist history of psychedelics to be
written I hope so and I hope somebody
writes it you know this is not the last
book on psychedelics I I think these
other perspectives need to be told I'm
not the best person to tell them perhaps
but but I hope there are many more books
to be written from a variety of
perspectives in terms of indigenous
peoples
you know it's funny someone stood up in
Cambridge and and and said something
that I found really upsetting she this
was the the second day of my book tour
this woman stands up from the Boston
Anthea Jin Network maybe she's watching
and she says as the de facto leader of
the psychedelic community it was a
psychedelic movement I was like really
and you know and Rick Doblin was in the
room the real and I turned him and I
made him stand up and absorb all this
fear juju and and then she went on to
say you know how do you answer the
criticism that there aren't more
african-americans in the psychedelic
community actually she said more people
of color and there actually are quite a
few people of color if you if you're
willing to go beyond the borders of
America and look at people in South
America and Central America and you know
the shamanic tradition there are tons of
people of color involved in ayahuasca
for example but she I think she was
thinking about African Americans in it
that's a really interesting question I
would get the same question about food
you know why aren't why don't we have
more people of color involved in the
food movement and there are legitimate
questions and and but first you know I'm
not a leader I mean you just made the
point I'm a newcomer how can I be a
leader I don't know enough to advocate
I'm still learning but people are hungry
for leadership definitely so anyway
there are you know my focus though I
think I wasn't trying to write the
comprehensive history of psychedelics in
the world
I was really writing at the center of
this book is a renaissance of scientific
research Western scientific research I'm
interested in the shamanic tradition
insofar as it influences that and and so
I go off from that spine but that's fine
is science and that science is is you
know is it's pretty white and pretty
male